[Music]
french elementary school children are
having to get used to wearing masks
i don't like it because i can't breathe
with the mask in the glasses
it's not the first time there's been a
mask requirement but infection rates are
climbing especially among children
we should never have taken them off it
would have avoided giving them a false
sense of joy the mask is compulsory
experts agree masks offer protection
against infection
many coronavirus cases could be avoided
if people covered their mouth and nose
and that's a lesson school kids in
france are learning
hi i'm ben fazoulen with winter here
mandatory masks are also a hot debate in
the uk
more than 140 000 people have died of
covert 19 there the highest death toll
of any european country
the face mask the most visible symbol of
england's restrictions free approach to
covid
england has one of the highest case
rates in europe yet there's no legal
obligation to wear a mask on public
transport and most indoor areas
is an approach that sets it apart from
the rest of the uk and much of western
europe
i always put mine on on the train and
going into shops and i'd prefer it if
other people didn't there seem to be a
lot of people
especially on the trains nowadays that
don't you know i work on public
transport so i think it should be on
we should be wearing them
but obviously
powers that be decided it's down to the
individual nobody should be forced to do
something within a private matter and
health obviously is a private matter
it's currently up to the individual to
decide whether they'd like to wear a
mask and yet in one recent survey the
public said they'd rather be told
81 percent of people said they'd like to
see mandatory mask wearing enforceable
on public transport so why isn't it
well that goes to the heart of
government
the divide over mosques is as clear in
parliament as it is in public with more
marks on the opposition benches than
among the governing conservative party
the prime minister himself came under
fire this week after he was pictured
visiting a hospital at points without a
mask
and accusations that the government is
setting a bad example are growing louder
we've had record numbers of infections
in parliament include including recently
uh the leader of the opposition uh kier
starmer so i think it's very
irresponsible and arrogant of the mainly
conservative mps they're setting a very
bad example uh to the public they're
setting a very bad example to the rest
of the people in parliament
the government says it's focusing its
efforts on its vaccine and booster jab
campaign and while cases are high
hospitalizations and deaths are
considerably lower than previous waves
but with fatalities in the uk averaging
over 150 a day the government's under
pressure to bring back masks and social
distancing
it is simply unacceptable to have
the equivalent of
a jumbo jet crashing every two or three
days in terms of the number of deaths
so we cannot rely on this vaccine only
strategy face coverings work
we can see that the countries that use
them have much lower rates than we have
the government is yet to rule out a
return of mandatory mosques and as we
enter into winter it will be up to
ministers to decide if and when high
case numbers become too high
but after months of being told masks
aren't legally required will the public
and the politicians be persuaded to put
them back on
and let's get the view on masks from
here in germany from ulrich pershall
from the max planck institute
how much protection do masks really give
you if we compare say the ffp two and
three masks
well if the two masks are certified to
reduce the particle output and intake by
95
and ffp3 are certified to 99
um and that means if it works well and
i'll come back to that in a minute
then the ffp2 mask can reduce the risk
of infection by a factor of 20
and the ffp3 mask can reduce it by a
factor of 100 for the individual and if
everybody masks up then you have to
actually multiply these numbers so then
you get to numbers of
404 ffp2 masks and 10 000
for ffp3 masks so these are enormous
efficiencies but what i would like to
point out is that the full benefit of
these very good masks you get only if
your mask really sits and seals tightly
and for this purpose it's really
important that they have such a rubber
such a rubber ceiling over the nose
because otherwise the leakages are
usually what determine the practical
efficiency of masks
what about other drawbacks like bacteria
build up a false sense of security uh as
we heard from the french woman earlier a
false sense of joy for those kids
well i i don't think that these
arguments are particularly well it i
think every mask is better than no mask
and actually when you when when masks
get back you usually really see it or
smell it so i think in practice
i don't think that there is
any downside to masks when they are
properly used and i think it's a really
important tool to use
one should just be aware that the full
benefit is really only reached when you
use them fully according to instructions
and when they sit really tightly sealed
and are you talking about the full
benefit for those wearing the masks or
others around you
actually for both sides so masks always
protect both sides they protect the
others from
both large droplets that we exhale so
that go by spraying on a short distance
and that goes both ways i protect the
others and myself and the same goes
actually also for those aerosol
particles
which are in practice just smaller spray
droplets so these are below 0.1
nanometers we talk of aerosols for
larger droplets
it's sort of ballistic droplets that fly
like this and for both of these masks
are good the large droplets even simple
masks can reduce with an efficiency
close to 100 percent actually even a
scarf helps along against the big
droplets but for the smaller droplets
for the aerosols we really need good
masks so a surgical mask is the minimum
but it's much better to use fft2 or ssp3
and what about the most useful
applications for the various masks can
you run us through some of them
well i would say definitely what we
heard before in the trailer is in public
transport or also in shops etc i think
masks
should be worn by all
and then i think in general in indoor
settings
i would recommend masks whenever people
mix
with people from outside their household
but actually also in outdoor
environments
it is useful to me masks when you are
closed by other people so within about
one to two meters you also do have the
risk of droplet infection that means
these larger droplets that we all exhale
they can still hit other people also in
the outside environment and a single one
of those droplets about one millimeter
in size or 0.1 a single one of those can
lead to an infection with a very high
probability when it comes from an
infected person
and again
against these masks against these
droplets
masks are very efficient and these
droplets also lead to infections in the
outside environment so it's not only
indoors just indoors
it's even more urgent to use the masks
and just really briefly all these as
we've said time and again on this show
it's not just masks that we should be
relying on should we
no absolutely not i think vaccination is
certainly the thing that i
would take first and of course i'm also
fully vaccinated but then the second
best thing is already the mask and in
addition to ask it's always good to
ventilate rooms when you're inside
or especially from the max planck
institute thank you very much for being
on the show today
welcome thank you
okay time for a viewer question about
the length of immunity provided by
vaccines
here's derek williams
what do we know about how long immunity
with vaccines will last
[Music]
this is another million dollar question
that'll just take a lot more time to
answer and answers will vary from
vaccine to vaccine but
here's what we know at the moment
a number of studies now support the
conclusion that protection against
covid19 after vaccination
with basically all of the vaccines
approved by the who
that it wanes in the following six
months
although
messenger rna vaccines in particular
have remained pretty effective at
preventing hospitalization
in recipients
the fact that growing numbers of people
are experiencing breakthrough infections
however even if most are not getting
severely ill
is behind new drives in a number of
countries that are now authorizing
and encouraging booster doses half a
year after the initial vaccination
especially for vulnerable groups like
the elderly and the immunocompromised so
what does that mean for the future well
a few different scenarios are possible
now that the idea of boosting is gaining
widespread acceptance one
is that like with a few other vaccines
such as the ones against hepatitis b
a third dose of a covid19 vaccine
could do the trick and create powerful
a longer lasting immunity um some
experts are hopeful that that will prove
to be the case
we're still gathering data on whether
mix and match approaches make sense so
the idea of boosting with a different
type of vaccine than the original
that might gain more traction as we move
forward
plenty of other experts however
are predicting that in the future
annual updated shots could be necessary
similar to the situation that we have
with flu shots but
as i said
that's something that won't really
become clear for at least another year
or two
[Music]